Jennifer first of all congratulations
your first uh Victory as the defending
champion and it wasn't easy you've had a
difficult event up to this point some
losses but finally today you managed to
break through your reaction to
that um well I mean this was I'm
obviously really happy with the result
actually this isn't just like my first
win this tournament this is literally my
first win since like January cuz I've
only played a couple of games no I've
only played like one tournament and then
I played like two games in world cup and
that so like it's been a while but um I
don't know I it always takes me a bit to
warm up in tournaments usually cuz like
if you look at my past us Champs results
from like before I won it was always
like this like I would get like one and
a half out of five and then like do fine
in the rest so um it feels good to kind
of get back in the get back with things
but yeah and you're a player that relies
very heavily on confidence whenever you
get confident you're a very streaky
player and a very dangerous oppon
opponent uh how do you feel about your
confidence after this important Victory
the first one since January as you
mentioned uh well if I I definitely feel
a lot better um it also like I was kind
of expecting something like this to
happen in the beginning just because um
it's been really tough with school and
all that to like kind of study chest so
I incredibly out of form like incredibly
incredibly out of form so I'm honestly
glad I just didn't lose all my games
because the way I was thinking I I was
just like missing everything but now I'm
feeling a lot better especially after
rest day somehow that's always a fear
whenever you play this closed events you
feel what if I score actually all losses
zero out of nine or zero out of 11 but
finally you got that important Victory
and it came after you started your
attack with this moment F4 very
aggressive take us through the remainder
of the
game uh well okay I honestly don't know
what the what was happening after Queen
H4 a little bit CU it was pretty
complicated um I don't know if I should
have let this queen H4 but because my
Rooks got a little awkward having to
defend the F4 Pawn but the second after
like E5 I just have these E6 ideas which
I think is really nice but um I think
she missed this E6 move after G5 but
yeah here I I I felt before um before
all this happened just like after F4 I
was feeling pretty confident um just
because it felt like a nice position
where I could just kind of you know
extend and do whatever I want as long as
I don't like hang a pawn or something in
Center absolutely guys any questions
because after that it was smooth sailing
for her attack yeah uh Jennifer
congratulations very nice game and kind
of straightforward attacking I wanted to
ask you about your game against Talia s
Cervantes because that was you were
worse after the opening probably close
to losing but you manage to like keep
saving that position for five six hours
until you actually accomplish to make a
draw what was your strategy in this game
and in general how do you kind of keep
on defending a bad
position well I honestly think that's
just kind of me my entire career if you
look at most of my games I'm just always
losing sometimes out of the opening so
if I don't want to lose every game you
just kind of kind of mess around um
create some chances so I mean I I just
if I have a bad position I'm not like
you know I'm just like let's make it a
little tricky for my opponent you know
it's not really something I like doing
but um I'm pretty used to this situation
yeah you made it more than little trick
it was very difficult to to win for
Talia so congratulation on that game as
well yeah your defense there was just
remarkable super human uh but H good
luck Jennifer uh for your campaign uh
it's defending champion and uh take us
to that game of Bon